[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we had ed orgeron a former lsu head
coach he was also a coach at usc great
recruiter one of the best recruiters in
the sport and uh kocho came in a couple
of days ago and i started the interview
by first having lis having him listen to
mark sanchez the former usc quarterback
his impression of coach at orgeron
answer it if you were coach oh talking
about joe burrow well
joe
number one go tigers
and joe you got the eye of the tiger
he got a heart like a lion
and you love him some gumbo
it's pretty good what do you think
what a go
i can't tell the difference
you know when you walk down the street
let's say los angeles what do people say
to you here coach what do you say man
how you doing yeah a great reception i
love los angeles spent 11 years here at
usc
great time for us what do you miss most
you know i miss the weather i miss the
people i love the people here in los
angeles i had a blast i thought usc was
a first class program i love working
there coliseum the games the recruiting
i recruited all of southern california
get to meet the people i've been in
almost every high school in southern
california great people down here how
did you close
uh if i'm a recruit yeah how would you
close me in the old days here's here's
the deal okay
manhattan beach sunday morning
me and pete would bring you down to the
strand be carol yes
we'd have breakfast in the strand
overlooking manhattan beach
and then i would take a personal walk
with each recruit
down the pier
and have a little talk with them and i
say you know what
check this out you come to usc you can
be like there's kobe bryant's house
there's this movie star's house this
movie star's house now i don't know if
they live there but a damn sounding good
do you lie to recruits you know what i i
basically i do a good job of listening
to what they want they will tell you and
i learned if you're a good listener
recruits will tell you what they want
and then you can deliver what they want
but name image and likeness how is that
going to change recruiting well it's
going to be the number one factor i
believe and where uh players go to
school
and uh you better have your stuff
together you better have a lot of money
ready and you better have a system
okay
what do you think was available at texas
a m when uh
jimbo fisher got all upset where they
had the number one recruiting class and
he made it seem like this had nothing to
do with
any of that oil money down there well
obviously uh i don't know
and i think those guys busted their tail
recording because i know those guys and
i think they do that
but i do believe that is a big factor
and i do believe you got to compliment
them they must have had a great system
on how to get it done
and uh because the players are going to
go where they're going to make the most
money
can you have a slush fund
you know here here's it's illegal
so to say
uh you're not supposed to be able to
direct the name image and lightning
escort according to the ncaa
but i do believe there's some backdoor
policies going on
that the guys that really the guys that
are doing a great job have a great plan
what was the craziest recruiting story
you ever heard oh my lord i got a bunch
of them yo one time no names no names no
one time we had a recruit i was at i was
at the university of mississippi
we had a recruit that was committed to
us
and we couldn't get in touch with him
and all of a sudden on the last night
that we could go visibility already go i
already visited him
i sent like nine of my coaches to his
house
and mississippi state was at his house
and it was a big deal and they was
calling me and stuff like that said
coach we can't get in there
i said keep on fighting keep on fighting
well stayed to midnight and that was it
well the next day was at that period
we couldn't get in contact with the
young man
they hit him in a church
in the back of a church
he didn't go to school to hit him sunday
monday and tuesday and wednesday
obviously didn't sign with us
who broke your heart is there one that
stands out oh adrian peterson oh
man i love them i love danger
oklahoma better offered a better package
to him this this true story
we go we go down to see adrian me and
pete and uh his mother ran track and i
think it was a houston wonderful lady
and
adrien and i had a great relationship
he loved pete carroll but i felt like he
and i were very tight one time he says
coach
i went to this school he says coach i
want you to follow me i couldn't i
couldn't drive with him
we went 30 miles
i said i don't know where we're going we
stopped at this little country store
and he bought a gingerbread cookie
i couldn't buy it for him for supper
and then we went to a basketball game
and we sat in the sat in the gym and i
said what are we doing
he said you see that guard right there i
got to play them next week coach comes
got him
how about that
then
he i said well adrian what is the key
to getting you here
at usc
he says cultural bob stoops my dad is
incarcerated bob seuss won't see him
well me and pete carroll tried to go hit
him
and to go see him they wouldn't let us
in
but adrian said coach my dad is be able
to watch my games
where he's at
well if i go to oklahoma
i tried to get the guy transferred to
los angeles
wait you tried to get adrian's dad
no that's right
how does that happen
i competed
i completed it couldn't get it done but
i competed he's uh ed orzeron the uh
former head coach at lsu why aren't you
coaching
well i want to take a year off
uh you know think about this i've been
going to university
since i started college for 42 years all
right
i wanted to think i want to just take
one year off
settle down let the dust settle i have
three great sons in fact my twins their
birthday today parker and cody they're
24 years old they all want to coach my
oldest son tyler's 29
uh we're trying to get them analyst job
get them in college because they were
all gonna be with me so there's a little
adjustment there we got one settled uh
one's gonna take the year off and one's
gonna try to get an nfl so i wanted to
spend my time working with them settle
down and then see what's available for
me next year was the lsu fair to you yes
i do believe listen i left with lsu no
regrets i knew one day that was going to
happen look hey you can't have two
losing seasons
that's the standard we set the standard
at 15 alone
and it wasn't there but look they gave
me a great settlement
uh i don't have to work again in my life
if i don't want so they were very fair
to me
what do you think of brian kelly's
accent
i think um i think i'm the only coaster
i didn't have to worry about an accident
i can tell you that
who was more important
when you were recruiting joe burrow or
jamar chase well
both are different you know i think that
jamar was committed to florida he was in
the state of louisiana
but i needed a quarterback
and uh
joel set the tempo for everybody
so i got to say it's joe and but that's
a hard question
but when did you notice though that he
had it
you know
so funny joe comes down and uh
he tells me to say coach i don't want to
talk to you
i don't hear your recruiting game i know
you're a great recruiter i don't need to
hear it i just want to talk football and
eat crawfish i said okay
i was kind of frustrated to be honest
with you i couldn't get my claws on man
every time i was trying to get them you
know no no
hey i never had a recruit didn't want to
talk to the head coach
so we have a football meeting and we had
set up some plays that he had ran at
ohio state some place that we're going
to run
his dad was in the meeting steve
enzomingle who did a great job offensive
coordinator jordan boone jones made the
deal jerry sullivan 74 years old i've
been in nfl for years i'm in there
and all of a sudden we start watching
the film i start asking
questions and i figured out immediately
that joe was the smartest person in that
room including me including all the
coaches and i was happy about it
and that showed me his football
intelligence what i saw in that meeting
yeah and that's that that's what you see
today
put that lsu team up against your best
usc team
give me your best usc team yeah yeah you
know 2003 2004 is good teams okay we
have some great defenses man who wins uh
it's gonna be tight it's gonna be tight
you know what i'm saying i can't say it
it'll be tight it'll be a tight game
it's a different game nowadays you know
we score more points
would you rather have joe burrow or
reggie bush
you know i i like reggie but what joe
burrow did for us at lsu he's the
greatest player in my my opinion in lsu
history and so richie
but but to have a quarterback to do what
you to me i i think to win the
championship you need a great
quarterback i learned that from jimmy
johnson get a great quarterback who's
smart and tough get great defensive
lineman
do you ever get in a fight on a
recruiting trip
like with another recruiter
we had some battles
what do you mean
we had some battle but and never gotten
a fist fight
but i wanted to though
who did you want a piece of you know i i
got to say i got to tell you the story
man this this is a pretty cool story we
uh
you know i'm recruiting sean cody usa
defensive player number one player in
the country los altos you know
and uh you jackson and i are commuting
from orange county
and he calls me sunday night he says hey
man where you got going i said i'm
getting my my visit ready for sean cody
he goes oh no you're not he says we got
to meet with mike garrett tomorrow
morning i said for what he said we're
getting fired
i said what
so
so we go there
and i'm sitting there and mike you know
mike says you know it didn't work out
with paul hackett paul was great to me
so uh he says listen
guys look i don't know what y'all want
to do i'm going to pay y'all if you want
to go look for jobs go look for jobs you
want to go recruit go recruit
well i got a mentor here in town brian
kennedy and a great man i called him
he says get your butt on the road
recruiting right now
so i go to schools
that day that they fired paul hackett
coaches are laughing at my butt okay
and i took
i went to one school and i'm not gonna
say the name but it was
he was a great recruiter
at ucla he was a recruiting coordinator
and uh the guy was not very good to me
not very good to me i left
i said i'm going to get you back
i'm coming
and i became the recruiting coordinator
and i took i took over orange county it
was you know it was a
big big recruiting area but also took
his area
you took his paper route yeah he knew
all that everything uh let's do the what
is coach oh benching these days
um
paulie i'll start with you now this is
one rep coach max one rep okay i'm gonna
go 310. i got a lot of confidence in him
satan o'connor uh
man i'm gonna go
no offense
290. 290. all right fritzi
340 was the first number to point to 40.
i'm gonna go 325 coach you guys are
there man you're right there what do you
got i'm gonna disappoint all of you
okay
and
i hate to say this i've got a torn
rotator cuff
i haven't been expressed in four years
believe it or not and i refuse to get
operated on my rotator cuff
so it's all it's all flies and stuff
like that but if i could
it would always be 3 15.
i promise you that 3 15. i probably
shouldn't all right fair enough
fair enough not bad
not bad could you take all three of
those guys no question
great to see you
enjoy time with the family there and uh
and you'll be coaching next year in
college uh we don't know i'll see what
i'll see what's the best thing available
i'm keeping all my options open
thank you bud thank you
the unmistakable voice of coacho eduardo